doing good makes you feel good but we
wanted to make some drew gooders feel
even better watch this
hi i'm saffron and i am the president
and co-founder of letters against
isolation and i'm sure i'm also a
co-founder of less against isolation and
saffron sister
at the beginning of the pandemic we saw
our grandparents who are suffering from
senior loneliness
one day our grandmother received a card
from a good friend of hers she was just
so over the moon to receive the letter
and we thought a letter must have such a
huge impact on the person that receives
it and so chery and i reached out to a
few local care homes and so within a few
days uh the four care homes we reached
out to all said yes we really need your
letters and what was intended to be just
a kitchen table project for stafford and
i became 200 seniors waiting for letters
so we figured we needed some help and we
posted online about it and it just blew
up now we have 17 000 volunteers it's
been amazing to be able to connect with
so many people around the world that i
would never have otherwise been able to
meet
i had a really exciting opportunity to
meet my 93 year old pen pal claire it
was so amazing to transfer our
relationship and our friendship that had
been building up over
pen and paper and actually meet her in
person i've always known that saffron is
incredibly smart and very very capable
but like getting to work with her i just
i saw that on a whole different level
thank you
hi guys i'm sono uh i am mum to saffron
and shreya a parcel has just arrived
from the drew barrymore show
how exciting let's go inside and
surprise the girls
there's a surprise here oh my goodness
what else where did this come from come
from the drew barrymore show delicious
that's so cool
wow
thank you for making a difference from
drew oh my goodness this is going to
help us reach so like oh my gosh oh my
gosh sweatshirts
it's really good
wow
these are so pretty congratulations
isolation thank you drew
to all the drew gooders out there thank
you
[Music]